quite clear that labour can't bring
themselves to even condemn these strikes
which are going to cause total misery
tomorrow and throughout the week with
people not able to get to
work to hospital appointments to gcse
and a-level exams it's clearly something
that the employers and the unions need
to sort out labor can't say that because
uh their union pay masters uh are the
ones calling the shots um but you know
the all i would say is
there haven't been any negotiations
since the 1970s as far as i'm aware
where it used to be beer and sandwiches
with the prime minister uh where those
negotiations took place and directly and
i don't maybe kirsten i think it should
be beer and curry or something i don't
know the point of this is that the uh
the actual unions need to sit down
with the employers because this is a
highly technical uh discussion around 20
different areas of modernization that
are required on the railway
to make sure the railways can continue
to function after we've given 16 billion
pounds of taxpayers money through
coronavirus through coronavirus to make
sure that none of those railway
employees lose that lost their jobs so
they need to they need to
work on this together between the union
and the employers so is is is
negotiation the only way out of this
oh absolutely and the crazy thing about
this strike is it was called by the
union bosses on false pretence uh that
there would be no pay rises that was
never the case because uh the pay freeze
which has impacted the entire public
sector during coronavirus had in fact
come to an end but the unions didn't
wait they balloted in april uh they
called a strike that will inconvenience
millions this week
it's totally wrong it's totally unfair
the average train driver earns 59 000
pounds the average rail worker
earns 44 000
the average nurse 31 000
they do not get a bad deal we want to
pay them more that has to be done
through modernization is that an
argument
sorry sorry to interrupt you is that an
argument you get paid a lot anyway a lot
of other people get paid a lot less
well only in as much as uh the
taxpayer has paid 600 pounds per family
for that 16 billion that we propped up
the railways by that's just put in in
proportion 160 000 pounds per railway
employee to make sure that no one lost
their job through coronavirus
they do get fortunately a reasonable
salaries i want to see them pay more but
in return we need to get rid of some of
these spanish practices which uh mean
that
that actually for example we can't run a
railway seven days a week sundays
sometimes some of the rail companies are
unable to find people to work because
the contracts
the bases of the contracts date way back
sometimes to 1919 when sunday wasn't uh
a travelling day as it would be now
we've got to have the modernization and
then we'll be able to uh pay more but we
shouldn't be having strikes about it
this should be a discussion there should
be a negotiation it should not be and
they've jumped the gun by calling the
strikes i'm afraid not only uh
threatening the the public with this
disruption but their own uh their own
industry and their own jobs by the very
fact that people can now use teams and
zoom and remote working where that
wouldn't be a possibility in the past
well the unions i i want to talk about
contracts and funding because the unions
argue and negotiation as you say the
unions argue that it's the treasury and
the department of transport that control
contracts and funding and so you should
be at the table
well as i just explained i don't name me
a strike at which a secretary of state
or minister or politicians have been
around their table the employers are the
people for the unions to have that
discussion with indeed mick lynch who is
the head of the the the rmt uh actually
said last month that he would never sit
down and negotiate as he put it with the
tory government he knows the employers
are the only people you can talk to to
settle this doesn't say there is more
money available that money needs to come
in return for reforming some of these
so-called spanish practices which mean
that for example we can't maintain the
railways as efficiently as we should do
using trains and imaging 70 000 pictures
per minute can be taken to check the
railways instead we still insist on
sending people usually men along tracks
it's dangerous we see deaths because of
this and this is one of the many
practices which hasn't been updated
because the unions refuse to allow
proper modern work practices to come
into well they say they do want to
modernize they say they do want to
modernize but
can the train operating companies offer
a pay rise because there are reports
that they have been told they cannot
offer one
uh yes the train operating companies uh
indeed the whole of the public sector
has a pay uh guidance and set out by the
uh treasury the more reform we can get
the more modernization the better that
offer uh can be but as i say the biggest
point of all is what on earth are they
doing going on strike why are they
stopping people getting to the hospital
appointments why are they stopping
people getting into their gc gcses and a
levels my daughter included as it
happens having a much harder journey
because of this why do that before
they've even done the discussions and
the negotiations is irresponsible and
why aren't labour for goodness sake why
aren't labour calling them out and
actually even condemning the strikes
they won't even say that the strikes are
wrong because the unions of course are
paying the labour party and they're
saying well why aren't you negotiating
why aren't you talking but do you think
that at two to three percent
exactly you know
since the 1970s and it wasn't very
successful under harold wilson when he
used to have beer examinations
do you think that a two to three percent
pay rise is fair when inflation is
pushing 11
well look first of all i say it's
important to know that the average
person working on the railway gets forty
four thousand pounds uh a nurse for
example gets thirty one thousand pounds
a care worker twenty years we're
specifically talking about inflation
we're not talking uh-huh but i mean the
point the my point is um that it's not a
badly paid um sector so this is not
we're not that's not what they're saying
they're not terribly powerful that's not
what they're arguing they're arguing
that inflation they just need um
a pay rise that they can actually live
with yeah absolutely and look i want
people to be paid more i want the rail
workers to be paid more the more reform
we can get the more modernization that
we can get which as i say has been stuck
for decades with all manner of practices
which just don't belong in the 21st
century then the better service we can
run for passengers and the more
affordable any pay rise so i can see
there's a you know there's a route
through from where they are by talking
to the employers to getting
this settled i cannot understand why
they are threatening the public with
these strikes indeed going on strike and
threatening their own sector and their
own jobs by jumping the gun to go on
strike it makes no sense and
unfortunately we've got a labour party
who refuse to condemn these strikes well
a lot of people are saying that actually
the public are behind them um but i do
want to ask you if it's all about
negotiation and talking things through
and coming up with the deal then what do
you think is reasonable for them to be
asking for
well again i just take issue with the
idea that the public are behind them the
public have paid 16 billion pounds 600
pounds per household to keep them in
jobs this is the way that the union
barons are thanking the public for all
of that money all of that contribution
to making sure that not a single person
lost their job i don't accept the
premise of your point secondly when it
comes to the negotiations uh if i can
explain the the uh the employers are
discussing about 20 different areas of
reform you know for example the ability
for people who are fully trained and
fully skilled to be able to move between
one terminal and another terminal in
order to provide flexibility to the
railway something with the moment
they'll only do with a large inducement
payment these are the sorts of
flexibilities that any modern
organization and railway should have and
those are the sort of things which would
enable
a a better settlement for these workers
but to be clear no one is talking about
a pay freeze all along there's going to
have been a pay rise and that is why
this strike is unnecessary and it should
be called off so
in terms of the pay rise what do you
think would be reasonable for them to
ask for
well as i say the treasury sets an
overall pay guidance i think it's uh two
or three percent uh for this year uh
clearly it's not going to be able to be
at the level of inflation if you carry
on paying at inflation or above you
carry on getting more inflation
what about i'm just gonna jump in what
about seven percent seven point one
percent well
i'm not going to start with
due respect to you uh on sky news and
negotiating in a negotiation that i am
not personally involved in there's a
nice
nice offer for you
the more reform that can be uh produced
and the better of the offer but i don't
think it will be anywhere near the
numbers you're suggesting no so
they're saying it's going to continue
for six months the summer does not look
very bright is your only answer this um
legislation that you're going to bring
in where you can bring agency workers in
to cover the striking workers
is that you're any solution age it's it
just correct that it's not agency
workers that we're after it's
transferable skills i mentioned somebody
sitting at a terminal uh in one of the
operation centers not being able to move
across uh and uh and assist at the next
one uh funnily enough unless a payment
is made it's that kind of flexibility
that's required it's sorting out the
maintenance side and the rest of it
so we'll certainly change the law uh in
order to provide those transferable
skills we'll also change laws separate
to that on what we call minimum service
levels it was in our manifesto it's
something that we've said we would do
during this five-year parliament it
would mean that the entire country
wouldn't be brought to a standstill
including freight including everybody's
ability to get to work and a series of
other changes as well i don't really
want to be spending time updating and
changing union legislation but when you
have unions who rather than talk about
it go and ballot for strikes under false
pretences unfortunately
that is where they've led us and that is
i i think a massive of great regret i
mean they probably argue
sorry to jump in they probably argue
that they are the ones at the table and
they are talking actually even you know
until the last hour but let me just let
me just bring you there so sorry just
okay
just to create that the employers are at
the table as as well the only time as
far as i'm aware they've not been at the
table uh was the unions on saturday
afternoon when they considered it more
important to go and uh go and rally at
the tu see mr lynch did refute that he
said that's not what they were doing but
in terms of the agency he used pictures
of him talking there right in terms of
those speech in terms of those agency
workers they argue that you won't find
people who have the skill set necessary
or the security clearance is that going
to be a problem
again this is i'm afraid the union's
muddying the picture we're not as i said
just a moment ago talking about agency
workers we're talking about people who
already work for example for network
rail or train operating company but is
multi-skilled and could move into
another role but like the classic old
union you know you can only do the job
that uh that you're supposed to be doing
that day uh you know contracts that we
saw of decades ago people made watching
this maybe don't know about how
unionized industry used to operate like
that it still operates in the railways
and that means we just don't have the
flexibility it's like trying to
conduct an orchestra but you don't know
which people will turn up which
musicians with which instruments and
where they'll sit because you've got no
ability to control any of that and then
expecting the passenger service to run
on time and we just have to move our
railways on from those old-fashioned
outdated outmoded ways of working